well sir there's no easy way to say this
um your wife isn't who she says she
is let me tell you what I
[Music]
see
trouble I
see a woman who outsmarted two
kidnappers are you okay ma'am
never do you
mention she is a
tiger she's claiming it never happened
never what now she's a wolf and sheep's
cloth in that one honestly I'm
embarrassed by all the
fuzz there is no one on God's green
earth who is a greater enforcer of the
laws of this land than Roy
Tillman why do I feel like there's a
butt here
butt you got any Weaponry back right
there got an air
[Music]
horn all of you people sneaking around
here pretending you're so nice but I
know who you really are I'm a winner
that don't sound accurate I'm a winner
yeah my
[Music]
ass better sleep with both eyes open
cut it out cut it out cut it out cut it
out it's good to see you again Mrs lion
that wasn't me first of all I recognize
you you were kidnapped and for the
record that's just reality with all due
respect we've got our own reality you
can't that's not a
thing fx's Fargo premieres November 21st
on FX stream on
Hulu